we are going to start with mr. ecto
regular come in
thank you very much I hope that the
future of Molina enriquez is not ours we
can have in this book something about
the influence which with the system
molino enriquez extraordinary book has
had although I'm afraid that this book
it will is heading in a very different
direction
about a future a modern Mexican future a
future of a country which can in be part
present in the history of others in the
laps of one generation cease being an
emerging country of cease being a sub
developed country underdeveloped country
and increase the per capita income from
eight to nine million dollars today and
become in the lab to the generation in
15 or 20 years a developed country by
country a country capita
above twenty thousand dollars per person
this is there that's included in this
essay this essay this man in an essay
it's not an innocent si it's not it's
not born from an occurrence I mean
intellectual we have had that tour he
and I have had it is born in reality
from a certain desperation of having
lived during too many years in Mexico in
in a public atmosphere lacking clarity
in political forces in the in the means
of communication academic and
intellectual environments in the
business community a lack of clarity
about what is the future the desirable
future for Mexico it arises from a
desperation in the public environment
context in which the country suffers
having lost the the course and having
lost ambition of being a great country
and of having lost in general the
agreements about some issues fundamental
issues which would allow it to become
again the great country that it was
meant to be and in this perception which
is highlighted in our or perhaps it's an
ambitious attempt to imagine with all
clarity the future which we think is
desirable for Mexico and to try not only
to make it
as a piece as an intellectual piece but
rather to make it to a certain extent as
a manifest as a proposal of of which
diffusion and promotion will be in
charge of with the point to place this
proposal in the realm of discussion in
the history of Mexico in the succession
of presidential in for the year 2010 we
would like to place this agenda in the
public realm as a reference not the only
one but as a reference in light of which
the different political actors have to
define themselves with clarity that's
out that's our intention with which we
do here in this book surely each one of
the proposals here are linked to we have
developed a book very well our proposals
barely pronounced they need a lot of
formulation preciseness to really
transform themselves into action but
their proposals that have an internal
connection unity not just a list of good
wishes or good proposals among
themselves if they don't have coherence
which we believe is the principal
purpose the most interesting
intellectual purpose of this essay
Mexico lost in the economic crisis of
the 70s and 80s the starting point the
the great
native of music that gave it definition
and sent to the public life in a very
demak false manner which is the the
heart of the Mexican Revolution the
president of the the last few decades of
the crisis said he will be the last
President of the rebbe Mexican
Revolution said do effectively his
government reached its end there was a
moment in which in the institution of
Mexican characterized by many things
that are still there but which don't
have credibility or force for example
there's a strong intervention of the
state very general hijama kin the public
life the pre and a president to owner of
this party in the drive of the political
campaign and with this all the
revolutionary myths of the state company
as a representative of the generational
interests the state driver fundamental
of the Society's strengths and forces
which would defend the demo democracy
and social justice as the objectives of
the post-revolutionary regimen it ended
this experience in the crisis of nova
note 94 and 82 and there was another one
that started which effectively the
substitution of all this system for an
economy which was more open more
liberalized its lesser less state which
the greatest and
peace has the largest consequences which
is the free trade the free trade
agreement with the NAFTA with since then
in the in the structure as a big enemy
to Mexico and the threat through this
NAFTA it has transformed itself into a
big opportunity for Mexico and this
proposal of modernization had had a lot
of strengthened in public and gave sense
to its course and it was key from Mexico
to be a first world country not a third
world one this proposal ended up in grit
in a big crisis in no venden in 94-95
very similar to the crisis 276 and 80 it
also ended the credibility of the
proposal of modernization in Mexico made
in the 90's the country remained with
the only course desirable in the future
with the process of transit current
democratic transition the Democratic aim
the director of all the public forces
and towards that they walked the
different actors of the political realm
with effectiveness until it was consumed
in two thousand the first in the power
democratic power and Pacific in the in
the history of Mexico and as of this
achievement historic achievement in the
Democratic conquest this this land
begins
this Democratic Lance is the MIT mythic
in the sense of forces which remain in
the public space and they can impose
they can drive they can establish an
idea for the future complex attractive
and and achievable by the government
democratic governments of Mexico
starting in two thousand and this
disenchantment of democracy begins with
the lack of results in demo democracy
for the continuous tie among the
political forces the disability to reach
agreements or not to reach consensus not
mainly supported by the political system
of the country and in this tie we're ten
years later the country returns to be as
I said it at the beginning of this essay
without the course without clarity
resigned to whatever is possible to do
in an economy and society and a
political system that requires changes
unreachable and it are these changes
that we propose in this book Jorge
Castaneda is going to summarize them and
speak in more detail of them but
fundamentally it will refer to for
decision strategic decisions first to
assume the changes in the economy which
requires to grow the second is very
important it's to decide the place which
it Mexico seeks to be placed in the
world the third is universalized the
rights and social justice to compel an
effective economy and country where at
least more than
two-thirds of the society will live more
or less in a middle-class situation in
other developed country and the fourth
is to make the democracy productive 30
reforms institutional reforms which
guarantee the citizens safety and
security those are the four proposals
summarized in this book of that Jorge
now will summarize thank you very much
now Jorge custody that will have the
word Thank You Johnny thank you very
much to all of you for being here thank
you John for inviting us thank you Tom
private a director of Columbia here
focus of the hospital a husband a little
support for this event very quickly I'm
not going to touch the social proposal
the minimum protection for all Mexicans
because the author will introduce that
our proposal and also if you want to
criticize him you can criticize him I am
NOT going to also talk about the fiscal
side berserk assorted sarala suelto talk
about it the first thing that after all
I talked in the essay was the obstacle
that our opinion is the principle is the
impossibility of the growth of the
Mexican economy there are several
explica and several excuses why that is
done it everything is done because of
the productivity the work in Mexico the
production in Mexico it happens also
because of more safe in New Mexico but
all that in our opinion has everything
to do with the great difficulty that
exists in the country to D concentrate
the power that the effective power has
as long as Mexico has a factor power at
the degree that it is all these other
steps which are fundamental are not
going to be impossible or very difficult
factor powers like monopolies or
oligopolies or companies that they
dominate or Union Sam Union only unions
have been and the democracy I have had a
great concentration of power energy
power the malapa monapali of Pemex don't
look at his hoes it's not his fault our
public have monopoly of the SMF a
syndicated mano jaan yamana Pollux that
it's in the education side of the
country multiple is in a which is
concentrated with the tvs monopolist of
the different political parties which is
very impossible to be independent in the
mexico city in a federal and state side
and now where the rage has lightened up
because of the Mexican power it's not
because this is due to the president
power that has given the rage against
this different politicians as long as we
don't know d concentrate the power of
this factor powers in this indicated
side in the financial in the economic in
the commercial in the TV in the media
and in the intellectual this until this
doesn't happen it will be impossible for
the economy to grow at the levels that
it's supposed to grow this is not an
only condition but it's a necessary
condition the second one the second
proposal that we wrote in this test has
everything to do with the text after
already mentioned it
is that to be able to burst the
creativity and the outburst of it we
needed to make sure that the savings
that the economic side are or were there
and also we need to bring know-how from
outside of the country and to be able to
do that from outside the country we need
to define what it means outside of the
country which is a big problem for us
because we have more than 100 years that
we have decided in those facts which
means United States but it has no until
today that we have decided that United
States as the one who's going to help us
so now we are in the middle of this kind
of like craziness that eighty or ninety
percent of our commerce that our
investment and tourism technology and
without even mention in migration
everything came from united states but
when we don't want to assume the
consequences of this fact especially
today one out of nine mexicans not born
in it mexicant land I live in united
states that is one out of nine it's one
of the highest number in the world
Ecuador and Salvador are also hot out
there the option for Mexicans not South
American but it's an integration with
commerce zone with United States with
Canada we said very clearly without are
any sugar coating to make sure that we
are able we're able able to provoke the
discussion which means i'll have the
cake i needed to the second one is to be
able to divide the wealth in a better
way but i'm not going to talk about this
but Santiago will be talking about this
same way the hisses he will be talking
about the fiscal side
given the resources that Mexico has a
minimum floor for the resources and be
able to have the the support for to be
able to achieve that but the last one
it's the institutional reform that the
country needs the political reforms a
little some they even say that it's at
the state reform that there are like
four or five different subjects that
they hair starting to be out there in
the public discussions as if President
caldern from mid-december had given a
10 or 15 different performance of this
type this we would like to think that
mr. Calderon inspired in his steps but
we don't have any type of illusions that
that is the case we are very humbled the
two of us so we would never have that
thought in our hand in our head but what
it is true that mr. Calderon his a team
to connote asst of the same Inca toad
stead are we had at that 1997 since pre
lost their majority in the chamber of in
a lower chamber and in 2003 when they
lost the presidency and they also lost
the majority in the Senate the last
regime all those older institutions they
do not work and they have the country in
the standstill situation in 1996 has
created some type of equilibrium
brethren the tier three different
parties equal elections clean very fair
but did not create any mechanisms to
create any majority in the chambers and
since 1997 there has been none therefore
they have me no performs his Susan
Rogers had always had the fortune to
have lived very closely the
failure of the energetic proposal of a
mistress Aurelio the failure of this
failure was due to the pan which in 1998
was a support of it in energy and that
he had the responsibility that he had
the reform that was very important
however not enough and not not enough
but now with being president of Pemex
now due to the crane now the country is
at a standstill situation because it
doesn't have any institutions that allow
them to make any decisions what we say
in this text actor myself they are
reforms that they're very simple not
very what we are not ever invent in the
wheel the second election the second
round of for the presidency election 50
purpose at least precedence and must
have against fifty percent of the votes
senators and deputies being held
accountable the legislative team be the
referendum to change the constitution
that the Constitution will be able to be
changed right now in Mexico it is
impossible to change the constitution it
now for example it's only able to change
the constitution only when it comes to
the medium calderon somebody from the
media says that occult Iran has been
able to change the constitution the most
of all the presidents but right now in
the Constitution you have to put that
hopefully we'll find more next year then
this year but there has been no
important changes in the Constitution
because with the regime of three
political groups with a change of
two-thirds means that one of them has be
able to have a veto power
the competence of the arena so the
president has more power and has more
influence over the Congress and also on
only we kind of like we make a hint
although we don't we say it but without
too many details it is very important to
have majority in the Chamber's
majorities doesn't matter which ones
impressions the preference of the
president so the president can governor
at least the first half of these period
but at least half of the of it of the
opposition but at least there has to be
some majority in the Chamber's Mexico
needs a very presidential power where it
has at least some majority in the
conference maybe this is the most
important subject that has to come first
in the sequence because if not the other
reforms that now they were Santiago and
hisses will be talking about will not be
able to be done and this one must be the
most debatable one now that we have seen
the discussion that the it's going on in
the country we have seen how effectively
that all conservator a conservative cap
a group it's not limited only to the
politics in the group but it starts in
all the different areas in Mexico we
don't like to change why we would change
but why we would change them we don't
like to change but the worst thing we
can do is to change without having the
certainty of where we are going but we
do think that we know we were going and
we think that these proposals are going
to allow to make decisions that's why
we're here with actor and Santiago and
hisses to discuss them with you and we
are going to continue to do it all over
the Mexican country and as well here the
United States thank you John and Tom
our dev way I give the floor to his
razor rollies thank you very much John
it's a it's a it's a pleasure to be here
in this academic institution sharing
debates about a such an important topic
and so it's a pleasure to meet with you
again I'm going to make for commentaries
about really the opportunity and the
purpose of the proposal of Castaneda a
second about the characteristics of his
proposal and the pertinency of the prop
corresponding proposal in the third is
about the coincidence between Carlos
what Calderon proposed and the content
of the proposal especially it's
important lastly I'm going to talk about
the three cleaves k keys for the future
of Mexico trying to wrap it up opposing
putting an order in my perspective the
proposals and elements that we have
obviously and as proposed in the book
the idea is to mobilize the society and
to have a discussion intelligent
discussion systematic about the
corresponding elements and motivate the
general incidents part for it to happen
a second and this is a proposal
obviously shared and it's to make sure
that the next election is more based on
platforms and proposals detailed
platforms than in the past which can
allow elements for programs for the
future of Mexico this is really an upper
opportune opportunity because it's the
time in our in our country for
this moment and it's also in based on
Calderon administration and all the
political forces of the country are
becoming aligned for the next electoral
situation in 2012 also due to the form
as seen with the second part of calderon
this the fact is that in both proposals
there's the discussion discussion about
Mexico which has been detained has been
fought has been some gotten smaller due
to the lack of a roof up deep reform
regarding the proposal I'm not going to
repeat what I believe is that the
elements there are two levels the four
proposals on the 21 of the book are
really long chapters and then the
specific proposal with more development
in the text i think these proposals can
be be summarized I'm but it's not very
relevant the fact that these elements
are there it's the point to start for
this discussion and to mention i'm
mentioning some of the chapters
obviously it's it's not the most
important topic the past which weighs us
down to build a middle class which has
proposals inserted about reorientation
the national goal less towards political
about poverty but political attacks
towards growth it's a reflection about
the situation in Mexico it's implicit
it's not explicit but that's the topic
it's a little contradictory that this
change of emphasis is accompanied in
other chapters regarding the size
society and the theme this distribution
of poverty but i think it's it's an
important topic about the construction
and monopolies and then the relationship
between the state and the union's and
then a chapter about the dem democracy
which has how to make democracy does not
it prevent a more efficient government
and three reforms proposed to produce
how to produce majorities how to provide
power to voters and how to achieve that
the executive have more capacity to of
initiative unless suppressed executive
like we have now in this respect that
the truth is there's a coincidence and
there's a coincidence between the
proposals of with Mexico with the future
and of Carlo of the president Calderon
there's a little bit of change in the
expression especially with the fighting
poverty cauldron talks about protecting
the society and the covered universal
coverage is to adapt the proposal of
Santiago levy in commenting and a
quality-oriented education insisted and
consequently one I think that one of the
first question is why is this
coincidence here it's because in reality
did you see the agenda of the de public
policy debate the cup the country has
sometimes
the country debates a long time now this
is the first observation that I wanted
to make but the second one is that the
fact that there is this coincidence i
think facilitates the following debate
and that we don't have to be looking in
the chapters just a few adjustments in
the headings and of the topics but we
can move through them very quickly and
and to pass to the next stage which is
the discussion of the contents in more
detail in about this i would like to
only speak about three points and one in
particular as the proposal what it lacks
is a sense of hierarchy and priority i
think that the stage coming in this
public debate in this public discussion
as the proposal for a future of mexico
requires that we do not spread out and
thin the forces after three or three or
four focus on three or four things so
it's more reachable viable and let's not
get lost in details i think that the
proposal there are really three
proposals and i'm going to say them
because i'm not going to concentrate on
them one proposal has to do with the
topic of overcome the fiscal precarity
for me it's like the mother it's not the
mother of all proposals but it's it's
important for democracy for the
government to become more efficient
there's also a third that's not in the
document but I'm just simply putting it
on the table so we can talk about it at
the time of question and answer is to
search for a social policy which is
based on the right of election among the
citizens I have many things that the
Mexican state has has been deciding for
the citizens for many decades many many
decades and the truth the following
step has to be based on the exercise of
of affecting after we can comment a
little bit more about that but really
about the fiscal precarity which is
absolutely critical because although all
the other reforms take took place if
there is no a soup a how do we
understand fiscal precarity the
insufficiency of these public sector
institutions in the investment and the
public sector which corresponds or
jenner is generated from a chronic
degeneration of the public sector
revenue in particular for the fiscal and
tributary revenue i think the numbers
are absolutely appropriate and it's
worth it to talk about two or three and
two thousand eight the last year we have
the most recent statistics the public
cost of the government took the total
government expense OCD implies federal
state municipal plus social security was
equivalent to twenty three point seven
percent of the pbi when the and then
it's 40 when many of the countries of
Latin America had coefficients of total
expenses higher than twenty three point
seven including the Social Security
we're talking about a stretch of about
eighteen percent obviously a government
of 23 and another government of forty or
a public sector are totally different
we're talking about two different
animals totally different and that's the
center of the debate how should we tax
and that's part of the country what kind
of country do want to be in the next in
the future it's not an economic problem
it's a main economic the main economic
problem of Mexico because if we don't
deal with it we don't resolve the other
ones the truth is that the public
investment for example has fallen in
Mexico during the last few years very
strongly from 6.7 of the pbi between 54
between 80 when Mexico was growing to
4.3 percent between 2000-2009 and
there's very clear statistics and
evidence that from in order from Mexico
to Mexican to grow it has the percent
has to be higher than twenty-three
percent and we haven't seen it in a
while this investment in a long time
higher than this percentage and of
course the conception is that the
investment in the public and the private
are complementary and it's a paradigm we
can the economy can grow if there's
public investment that's not the case
there are certain investments that can
there are others I can't and this is
what we have to resolve in order to
simply indicate the the income I'm going
to talk about that that in 2006 the last
available statistics compared the income
total income of Mexico was was
equivalent to twenty point six percent
of the pbi the federal organized States
was thirty four point two percent there
is a gap of thirteen point six percent
of in fiscal income total fiscal income
between Mexico and other countries but
the composition is a composition and so
if they indicate where the areas of
opportunity which have to do with the
country that we want to achieve
and we can imagine a country without
imagine it without a financial structure
and who has to generate the the income
i'm going to pass through numerous the
federal government in mexico 11.9 in the
Oh Sadie 14.8 this dates 33 % 6
municipal 0.9 percent of the gdp there
it doesn't exist in OCD 2.8 and Social
Security is a topic that Santiago knows
very well for his academic work
three-point-two percent in Mexico nine
point nine percent in the average of the
OCD you can imagine what this number
means for the future of the system of
pension what type of country do we want
to be also we want to know what type of
pension system that we want to the
country to have so please I just want to
make sure that this is on the table the
truth of the matter is the
interpretation of the income has to be
consistent with the type of country that
we have and that has to do to do with
how things are divided what goes to
social security to the municipal to the
states this is the state cannot tell
what the municipals can do and that
cannot be the case this is one of the
things that citizenship demands one
thing to make an notice be sure that the
success of gathering taxes by the
government bottom line all these numbers
they seem to that we are looking at the
government there are two points to an
half points of additional taxes that's
not what I mean the main difference is
in Mexico the differences in a municipal
governments if we put all this
load on the federal government then all
this is way too ambitious I live it over
there so then we leave it for the Q&A
session thank you very much finally we
are going to hear from mr. Santiago levy
good afternoon to everybody first thank
you very much John for your hospitality
it is a pleasure to be here in Colombia
and it's a double pleasure to have
without Jorge at rehearsals to share
this debate with all these issues that
we are so committed to the country I
want to make sure that all my comments
are personal my comments and it's not a
part of the IDB I just expressed my
opinion because it's what I am concerned
with I would like to point out that the
main problem in the economy in Mexico is
the social problem and if we do not
understand that the two of them are the
same problem and we speak about the
social problem on one hand and the
economic problem on the other one we're
making a mistake the principal problem
is that the country grows very slowly
and creates very few jobs and the jobs
have been stagnant and we don't have a
social security cover that the country
is a stagnant I want to make sure that
this problem is different to the problem
of the crisis this problem is much more
its holder and it's almost three take
it's old and it's important to
understand why this has happened with
our country it is not because of the
Mexicans we work very little if you see
the hours that the Mexican work and the
participation of the workforce the
effort that they make from monday to
friday that they go to work they work
very hard it's not any difference than
the how often other
it works with other countries we do save
less than in South American there are
the South American countries but our
savings are not that low the main reason
that they're bright the country is a
test argument and the real salaries are
stagnant is first the politics is
stagnant and if we cannot increase the
productivity we are not going to be able
to compete with Asia with other
countries in the world and we are going
to still keep keep on being stagnant as
we have done it for the last 30 years
actor has said it at the beginning of
this debate that we want to be a country
with future that we look in the future
why the stagnation in the productivity
this has many reasons but this one is
the one that I want to point out the
informality the informality is a big
problem that there we have and it under
estimated sixty percent of the workers
in Mexico more than than fifty percent
have like an in a formal job 11 job here
one job there today they are
self-employed tomorrow they're like work
in a small company tomorrow they are
being hired by in a legal way six out of
10 are being hired in this way and most
of these companies are not being
registered in the formal way all these
companies are illegal and the
combination of more of the fifty percent
of the population and more of the fifty
percent of this companies that there are
also legal drive to the stagnation of
the country why because the small
companies you don't do a lot of our
technological innovation you don't have
any economies of scale there's not a
much dynamic and dinah dynamics and that
is why the real wages are stagnant the
presser who cleans the windshields today
in Mexico tomorrow has the same
productivity has the same productivity
the day after has the same productivity
and in five years has the same
productivity they are not increasing
their productivity
and this increases in a great illegality
because most of the companies they spent
their time to hide him from the IRS and
not to training their employers or in
enough being innovated and technology
this illegality has a major problem for
Mexico and has the governor government
in a one rogue spot the country will not
be able to build a future imagine that
you see a great amount of workers that
they'd have any social benefits no
pension no health care no protection
against any dangers no social security
the state against their situation says I
have to provide some urban social
benefits and I'm gonna give them through
some programs then I will be financing
through the taxpayers money but at the
same time this employees that are being
hired the formal way that they're being
hired the formal way are paying through
this type of program suppose they are
being subscribed with the IRS the
problem with Mexico is that the state
says to the governor to the workers if
you are informal i'll give you a health
care solution but if you give get
yourself a legal a legal job I'll take
that health care problem health care
benefit away and you get are you we have
to pay for one but if you are formal you
will have to say for your pension and
the companies they said if you are a
formal company and you hire somebody
legally you will have to pay for him but
if you're illegal and you hire somebody
we are going to we are going to price
you but we are going to give those
illegal workers the benefits that you're
not paying for and
this dilemma is a very difficult one
because the government has to give those
benefits so social benefits that the
population needs and work their
distribution of resources what happens
at the bottom at the end is that they do
more of illegal economy with this didim
in 2007 2008 2% of the gdp would go to
subsidize the social problems to break
away the illegality and to innovate
those products productivity jobs and
less then two percent of the gdp will go
to those legal jobs and we have come
into this vicious circle as this
companies are very small the social
system real wages they get stagnant and
this requires a major redistribution of
the resources from the government and
this makes motivates more the informal
jobs ninety percent of the companies in
Mexico has less than five workers these
are small companies very very small
companies and these are the ones that
their sensors capture another important
data the urban side of the urban sides
of the country almost fifty percent of
the workers are not even in a permanent
address there in the street leaving
selling gamma during shoeshine why a
worker of 25 years old that hell knows
how to read and write that knows how to
count that he can make changes is
working in the street and it's not
working in a company they are more
productive what is the problem here the
thesis here is that the incentive that
is motivated by the best intentions of
the state to give all the social
benefits but in the inning that's good
in theory but in the practice has been a
very
has been counterproductive and this is
the cause of the tightening of the
taxpayer our taxes at the base tax and
most of these comp workers receive
social benefits without having to pay
for them if mexic was not able to get
over this problem the country will not
be able to get a future and this problem
is not resolved by spending more yes you
have to spend more but before you do
that you have to understand the main
problem between productivity and the
social benefits and make the changes in
the judicial and institutional side so
these changes can take place what I
propose is to resolve this two problems
at the same time and at the same time if
we solve them at the same time you've
solved the two of them or you can solve
any and the proposal is to extend all
the workers in Mexico social benefits
this proposal is a social law benefit
social law for social benefit for Social
Security for pension we can also say no
hi if there are enough or not enough but
not all the workers and legally employed
today but if not its workers that the
law it's a right that the workers have
for men women poor wealthy it doesn't
matter also simultaneously this proposal
what I want to do is to finance to
finance this proposal with taxes through
the consumption are not as its earned
today and directly that the wages of the
companies we have so many companies so
small that they take a lot of time
trying to evade or avoid the IRS and
people working in the streets trying to
sell whatever it is
and that those they do pay taxes which
is a very small amount has to subsidize
the subsidized the social benefits of
those that are not making any type of
contributions I I propose that everybody
paid taxes according to their amount of
money that they make so nobody has any
purchasing power losses and purchasing
power also the companies would generate
more jobs with a better quality with
more purchasing power so we can compete
with no more productivity the country
will not be able to go against the power
at the poverty this program will not be
the answer to the poverty in the country
this program has to be complemented with
productivity jobs with higher paying
jobs and abroad what we don't want is a
an amount of workers that they're always
on poverty plans all the time the
objective is for the poverty to
disappear if we maintained event the
poverty man stains as possib we have
maintained it if we want to erase the
poverty we need to have jobs much more
productive because that guide that's 25
years old that was for fourth year of
primary knows how to read and write and
process of reverend works in united
states and becomes one out of 10 has a
productivity six or seven times higher
we need a fiscal reform that is not done
at the same time with the social room
for with the social reform it will be a
big mistake increase the taxes to
continue increase the illegal hiring
would be a big mistake what the country
needs is a big reform in the sole fiscal
and social side at the same time and it
make the applicant forum
to me
the book is called a future from Mexico
the authors are actor Aguilera coming
and Jorge Castaneda in a sense it's a
book it's a platform political platform
that looks for political candidates and
the first stage in the search is the
discussion of everything that's found in
it on its pages I would like to
congratulate the authors and the
commentary 'used here present and thank
you the audience for your presence and
now we're going to finish this part of
this panel which is is issued live to a
public in Mexico to pass on to start the
discussion about what we've heard two
announcements the first one the book is
an sail on a table here if you would
like to buy one this after it's cheap
very very cheap second we have here this
night tonight unha Lee's master data the
novelist of of the first Mexico Mexico
merida mexico which is at this similarly
the the wife of aguilar come in and for
her due to her presence we have the
advantage of having her her film of her
first novel iran come in la vida at nyu
tomorrow at 5pm for those who would like
to see it
and after the film at NYU there will be
a discussion with antilles now i'm going
to give the floor to director executive
director of the cipa excuse me school of
who will carry out the question and
answer session on what we've just
listened to if you would like to make a
comment or a question please make it
brief and make a line behind just what i
would like before I would like to thank
you the two thought authors
distinguished authors it's it's it's
very an honor for us to have you here
and it's it's amazing to reflect upon
the problems of Mexico and Latin America
and how they're in common here in the
United States even the US and the rest
of Latin America especially I would like
this to be a space to reflect and create
a dream to create a space dedicated to
in columbia and the institute of latin
american studies to reflect about mexico
and the great proposals presented
innocent in a simple form Sookie the
plug I was again I would like to thank
you very much I have my own questions
but I would like to give the floor to
thank you I'm good afternoon my it's a
quick question Jorge Ector the cleat for
Mexico that the three parties if the key
that they have for the changes aren't
going to happen how how can the society
impulse and motivate the changes
individual and
pending dependent it's a complicated
situation in Santiago sober the in
formality I would like to add about
corruption I understand the business
environment and as far as the the
union's the relationship it's impossible
to do business in Mexico I don't know if
you'd like to comment about this well we
have many we have a lot of confidence in
the in the politicians and in this
mexican society with respect to this
this situation we've had a very good
experience for us with an art with Jorge
and I to have a lot of response X
outside of the academic sphere and
regarding the proposal what's happens
we've gone to many cities in Mexico to
speaking about this and universities
with the local press and the business
community of the cities and even with
the politicians themselves who
approached us to speak about our
impression express today from a
different angle is that it's a moment I
specifically opportune to propose change
on a grand scale which are placed in
this book and those referring to
referred to by his ooze and Santiago but
why because the money the public money
is arriving to a critical crossroads
there are there's a lack of finance a
progressive lack of finance and
extraordinarily fast in the public
treasury there's a growing consciousness
among the actors players of absolute
dependency on the political politicians
that have with respect to
this Treasury in decline there is also a
public impression very which is very
important towards the politicians on the
part of the the media the public opinion
of the society mexican society to the
point where the dip you tease deputies
and senators in all of the surveys have
a level of credibility which is lower to
the police officers this one can think
this that's one is cynical that's not
going to have some consequences but
aside from the professionalism which
requires the pout that required by the
politics the truth is that nobody likes
this situation now we think that they
have the experience the different
parties have the experience this this
system in which they are in isn't
working for example a brilliant
technocrat like Cedillo a great
communicator populists who was fox and a
lot of a president with a lot of
parliamentary experience like Calderon
have tripped over the same stone which
the app which is the opposition to block
and Jorge has formulated that very
specific in 95 Cedillo proposes of
reform and for the electric electric in
Nova in 98 the electric sector who
blocked it the leader of the opposition
party in the Congress opposed it who who
is the leader of the National Party in
this moment in Congress Felipe Calderon
now Felipe Calderon is is the president
that needs the reforms and he Dupree
fundamentally is the party which gave
them we think that
that it's obvious even for politicians
who are involved in a situation that
it's been increasing this problem and
the campy can't keep going down the same
road because the whole world starts to
lose what is want gained and this is our
expectation that that in the midst of it
all an opportunity there is a clarity of
vision and a clarity in the pin the path
for all of the political forces which
hopefully will coincide with what is
proposed here but even if it doesn't at
least that it has in effect that these
political forces which are manifested
declare their commitments and be
responsible for their decisions because
otherwise it's a very burdensome
annoying stale situation in Mexico
because nobody is responsible the
president it proposes initiative to
Congress the Congress half of it chant
accepts it half of it rejects it it
becomes a a camel after political force
says that the responsibility out of this
deformity is of the other political
party everybody the government
celebrates the reform thinness the
necessary and possible reform the
political forces don't understand each
other and a little time after we're
speaking about the necessity of another
reform and who's responsible nobody
knows who plays for this deformation who
it's not clear and this lack of
responsibility and clarity is very
damaging
very as a little summary here about
corruption this subject has a there its
own dynamics at the end it has something
to do with the citizenship and the state
and the citizen doesn't receive what he
is entitled to from the state this is
dude two part of the future for Mexico
has to do with every construction
between the relationship between citizen
and state that the citizen feels that
the state gives them and the citizen
values what the state gives them so they
start to have some shameful regarding
the corruption that corruption has
always existed but the levasseur can
always be lower and that is still
because the citizen see a state in a
different way we are going to go whether
the second question thank you very much
my name is Juan Carlos kiddos I would
like to ask you a question that has to
do with the proposal with dr. Levy's
proposal regarding the reform that tries
economy and social reform handy hand it
sounds like a great idea that basically
is tried to buy with economic rights our
fiscal reform but this brings me to the
general question then the proposal is
run by the author's proposal who's going
to guarantee this right and then will be
implemented and how this will be
implemented because this is one more
thing for the state that the stage
already has problems to give results and
this kid brings me to the second
question that mr. various role is it is
necessary that there are more options
for the citizens and this is what
what I find it very little in the
proposal you speak a lot about right but
you don't mention too much the freedom
it is very easy in it as you know in
Mexico to create new rights but it is
necessary that this right to be
implemented why is it so difficult to
create an agenda that is based on the
options for the citizens and in freedom
of the citizens even if these freedoms
are due to reduce the power of the state
very good question to whom to Santiago
you did perceived a very well I am
looking for every fiscal reform through
the social reform but I'm not only
looking for every fiscal reform I'm also
looking for a Productivity reform that
the real salaries will be higher and
that the companies more competitive what
is going to guarantee that the key here
is that what I had been emphasis is that
a fiscal reform with a lot of
unsatisfied needs and the state has to
have more resources there will be a big
mistake to spend more of what we're
already spending we are running or
spending it's a very big mistake what we
need to do is part of to legislate that
income the source of income and where
that income is going so in that Garrett
so the guarantee will be placed there
I'm not trying to say that to put
attacks just to put the name of attacks
but what I'm talking about is talking
about taxes and spending together then
we can say what is the federal
responsibility the state responsibility
but what the key is here is that the
Congress doesn't have to say till the
citizens I'm
increase your taxes you trust me and I'm
going to be a very good resource manager
I'm going to increase your taxes and
that money is going to be to create
better jobs and to make sure that
everybody has a pension health insurance
and this I are the article specific
articles that that is going to happen
Santiago let me ask you with your
experience with Latin America how much
different is a mexico in the different
different differs from other countries
when it comes to Social Security's and
benefits or is it very similar I think
that the informal problem it's something
typical from South America better Mexico
maybe because it's a good tradition that
comes from the Constitution that state
that is supposed to divide the resources
has created this parallel benefits for
the informants many years ago that's why
Mexico is a little bit more advanced
than in the rest of Latin America but
Colombia is not that by the right behind
the problem is this problem is a problem
in all the region your comments hisses
let's go a little bit more in depth of
what Santa has said what I think is that
it has not been dedicated enough time to
explain they're a real transformation
when it comes to health care in our
country or even education requires
transformation very important of the
offer of this type of services generally
you don't speak about this type of
subjects because it's making a
confrontation with the unions that offer
this type of services but the basic idea
but in the United States which is a very
common idea is that there's an offer
side that allows the family or
the person at what hospital or what dr.
on what way he is going to have the care
that it is a main issue for the next
step in Mexico the same thing happens
with the education here are the
extremists their families go from one
County to another County so there's the
cherenkov got a school that the parents
want well the states in Mexico still are
the children go and particularly at what
room the children go if for the vast
majority of the Mexicans so the problem
here or what we need to have and keep in
mind is the discussion of desert
transformation of the system of offer
and that would cause the ruffling in a
very important unions that is based in
the monapali construction that are under
costanera an angular a very short
question for mr. Cassadine Union what
has to happen between the drug war and
mr. Calderon so all these reforms are
valuable because the organized crime
lately has been the main topic in at the
politicians agendas that is a very good
question but it is not exactly the
question why we have been asked to come
over here when I'm going to say that
actor now we make three proposal
regarding security that we think are
very important as far as the unique
uniformed police and to try to
substitute the 2,000 municipal police
men with a 32-hour State Police it is
not enough step and a good one to go
also to create an interior minister with
less politics as possible so this
Polly's can be concentrated there and
the rest of the security can be
concentrated from there
we don't have any dreams that the
interior minister would not be
absolutely out of politics but at least
as minimum as possible with politics we
also talked about the fighter with hand
in hand up with United States about the
having certain drugs being of free of
trade now what I think that I said it
actor that the secretary Fernandez
Commerce month that according to the
deputies of the pre that started to go
back to session that after the what
happened in quarter city those horrible
and terrible incidents we needed to
think about the reform about the
security law before talking about any
reform in the politics side there are
there are reforms in the chamber of
deputies and senators that they are all
the the about security energetic reforms
I don't understand why they cannot be
speak of two things at the same side I
don't understand why they cannot eat a
taco and work at the same time I don't
see where the difficulty is there is no
reason why to keep on postponing this
while we keep on winning the war against
the drug trafficking we can have very
different opinions but in all these
cases is that it's not going to be one
tomorrow is to wait to keep on
postponing a lot of reforms that are
fundamentally nowadays and then also
this could help the other one I
recognize a Jorge Antonio campo to I
have two questions with esta observation
let's let in
this topic of Rico knows recognize the
destiny of being next to this great
neighbor where we are now may it appears
to be a very logical question a question
but where is the role of Mexico as the
leader of Latin America in it's not the
it doesn't identify it doesn't have an
identity of a developing country which
allows it includes including like in
Brazil to have a leadership be both
Latin America and developing world and
so where does the role of Mexico fall as
a leader in this in this sense because
it was always traditionally in this
respect and the second question it has
to do with the observations of Santiago
in the International fiscal comparisons
in Latin America Mexico included and the
OCD that the great difference between
the individual salary and the
contributions to the society so let's
say my question is how can one have a
tax structure or contribution towards
the state without having contributions
to Social Security the proposal of
Santiago goes in in a sense of
eliminating the contributions that the
state guarantees is the general tax I
wanted one of the general universal
benefits where is this pillar of the
Social Security that's one of them find
most fundamental pillars of the social
structure of the OCD thank you very much
quickly I think that it's the great
pride for Mexico having had positions
of the in the vanguard in international
issues in a Latin America but though but
it's that regarding leadership is a
total in invention is overall especially
when there's the best moments in
diplomacy of Mexico represented by the
Ambassador is when we were alone not
only we were only leaders we were
totally totally alone 54 in the
conference of Caracas about the the
Guatemala obviously without breaking off
ties with Cuba in 61 62 and went to the
last day and then having been knows not
just with breaking ties with Pinochet in
73 but also in having detained the pot
the thought of the systemic refugees and
Chile and exile is only in this
statement on El Salvador we had to go to
get the French people because nobody in
Latin America wanted to side with us we
didn't if we hadn't found the Frank
French speaking people this theory that
Mexico Mexico was never a leader in
Latin America we had positions which she
were shared with the dictator which went
against the dictatorships but we never
followed when and we were never followed
and perhaps with a small exception but
that was when we were a lot and we
weren't one or two we were many so it
seems that we have to be realistic
Brazil has power in Latin America due to
its diversification and commerce to have
six countries bordering it to have a
diversification in its investments its
exports everything Mexico does not have
that possibility but it's not that we
are losing it and we lost it now we lost
it 100 years ago Mexico concentrates
everything John mentioned the book on
the Porfirio trains
um Warren's even built for the south for
the north for the East the West only for
the North or they're down here down
mexico or Mexico up I think that yes
it's something effectively we must but I
don't know if resign ourselves but or to
regret but we have to see things as they
are and where are we where have we been
in the last 30 years and where is it
convenient for us to be and that's going
to imply decisions very difficult
decisions in Mexico and that's what
actor and I are proposing that people
decide that thing deliberate I hope that
there is a candidate for presidency in
2012 that would say openly I want to
destroy the the free trade with the
United States I want to diversify the
import Mexican imports for example
starting with the 2012 I want to place a
tariff to all of the corn imported from
the united states and i don't want to
subsidize any type of the imports of
corn from Brazil because I prefer that
were partners or dependence on Brazilian
corn rather than the US that's what i
propose to you as Mexicans vote for me
or not I want to see I want to see one
who who dares to say it and to who would
vote for him who in Mexico would be
available to pay more for corn in Brazil
because it's not gringo it's not
American if there's one here please
raise your hand because in Mexico
they're not there and the second half of
the question I think corresponds to his
usar Santiago I think it's very good
jos Antonio my proposal is to duplicate
the contributions to
security three to six percent of the GDB
what we can debate it the most important
point is that if we want to continue
with the same scheme in where the
contribution is associated with the
salaried work scheme it's a right to
receive a salary because the
contribution to social security is the
right of a worker including employees
rural workers domestic workers all
workers and if there's if we and so in
what I'm saying is that in state of
collecting Social Security at the door
of the company like in in the event we
would we would charge the benefits at
the door of the store with a huge
difference all passed through the store
but half does half of Mexico doesn't go
through the the factory who says that
the politicians are slaves of slaves of
a politician where it's slaves of a dead
politician Bismarck said that that's how
social security resigns thank you very
much thank you very much I have a
question for Santiago it's the regarding
the reform to the sustainable
sustainable ax t I don't see where we're
regarding it at least in the context of
mosca so with with respect to Latin
America that you know better reforms to
sustainability development in 2009
reports that sixty-five percent of the
population in Latin America is
concentrated in urban areas I don't see
except in the case of other cities
that's developing policies that go
linked to the topic of the productivity
for example cities and with an
infrastructure can
chief is specifically a question of
viability to achieve metropolitan we are
ready do you refer to sustainability of
the environment environment and
obviously a better infrastructure
especially because the majority of the
population in Latin America are located
in urban areas I'm I don't know if I'm
the best person to comment that need not
even then and in the essay or the
proposal talks about the environmental
topic not because it's not important but
clearly a Democratic Society talked
about by Jorge is more related to topics
proposed in a more systematic area
although it doesn't mean it's not an
important topic I don't know if anybody
else would like to comment on I don't
want to take away importance but I don't
feel ready or prepared to comment on
that I think that effectively our
content is it's something that must be
proposed in a version in a subsequent
version do you have it here because it's
a topic every day more that's everyday
more important in a country has a
situation very very regrettable in
regarding land I think it's doing some
some efforts to there's a multiplication
of treatment water treatment plants and
drinkable water plants and at least it's
begin their bit if we're going to
reflect in a few years on this about the
contamination of water there are many
other topics that I don't really have an
evaluation on the topic thank you very
much
it is very important this subject but
this is implicit in the air say this
essay is based is they are thought up
with an urban Mexico in mind this is
thought after the rural Mexico the rural
Mexico represents in this moment less
than four point four percent of the gdp
in Mexico the majority of the gdp that
four percent is how the majority of the
river culture is in the country the
change in society then we are talking
about the value of the industries in
Mexico in a very recent data that was
gathered is around five percent above
the GDP the cultural assets there
produces Mexico value is worth more than
what the rural world air produces this
is an essence that has been thought with
an urban Mexico but you're still right
there is a central subject that we have
not talked about it because we did not
have something specific that we had to
bring to the table or at the end we have
made taken matter of the this subject
and other subjects that we have spoken
here this essay has been thought about
four different points we talked about
the beginning and the end of the
modernization that has been stated here
the validity of the state the
sustainability of development the
generalization of the instruments of the
knowledgeable society and the
transparency of the public accounts no
no reform has been based on illegality
destruction of of the
surroundings with before we go to our
next questions I would like to thank the
the presence of Robin Beltran that is
one of the ambassadors and all the
revenues from the ambassador of Chile in
the United Nations now we can go to to
this question my name is Alejandro
Cardona i'm also in c / and i have a
question and a precision that i think
it's worth mentioning the question is
regarding the public expenditure it's a
very important engine for the
development of our country and any other
we are way below another OCD countries
in Latin America but besides increase in
the public expenditure the public
expenditure has been 3 billion pesos and
there has been increasing year-over-year
and moreover the public expenditure has
also been talked about the quality of
that expenditure because in education we
have more than a hundred million pesos
are that we have go to our school but
it's classed with the unions so there
should be some type of quality controls
I don't know if there's some type of way
to mention those type of mechanisms the
proposal of presidency region about the
energy reform it was the privatization
of privatization of the energetic
Commission and it was rejected by
unanimity of our society there was a
blocked in our country and their
proposal of mr. Calderon was to reform
the Mexican oil companies was only to
participate in the para private sector
it is important that there was a
blockage Donna through the two political
parties in
the energy and the other one was only a
practice a private participation in the
pemyx company I think that the question
is relevant thank you so much Alejandra
for your comment and your question
you're absolutely right when we discuss
the insufficiency the difference between
expenditure it has to be done in a very
knowledgeable way in the way that that
expenditure is done what I think it's
very personal is that in the last years
or even decades the argument that has
been inefficient usage of the
expenditure and the corruption it's
absolutely obvious that gathers you the
conclusion there first you need to solve
that a problem and then you have to talk
about the insufficient expenditure a
nitrogen that has been used to block the
discussion on the subject to be able to
unblock this has to be done
simultaneously on both sides we have
very examples of their totally opposite
wonder what the other one the case of
health care has been increasing the
expenditure in the last year's first
because of an inkling increment of a
public infrastructure that is not
justified that they are not necessary
but also due to another type of
initiatives the resources assigned to
opportunities that is to say original
opportunities I'm a bigger program with
more channels to spend has increased
substantially also has increased the
expenditure to go towards health care
the way of joining it has the
implications that Santiago levy has
mentioned
the secretary Frank to be able to
increase the resources to health
insurance so little by little has been
able to increase the dev resources to
health insurance which has been a very
good strategic move also there has been
other ratios that have been incurring
increasing the public expenditure has it
done right or wrong well I think there
was kind of like ours also I I don't
think that we can say that we consent
that the public expenditure is like kind
of like a Satan when you pay an nurse or
you pay and teacher that is a public
expenditure so let's not make you know
the public expenditure like Satan we
want to have a better social benefits
but we don't want to keep on spending
that makes kind of like no sense so that
kind of like we have to analyze in a
complex what do we want to know to have
regarding pensions we have liabilities
that have not been funded there some
resources have been devoted to them to
the problem of the pensions the inner
president there the beginning of
caldrons presidency it was resolved the
Easter issue which was also brought some
of the social security issue and the
public account also you see those
expenses so you have to c XM in
education we spent more than any OCD
country but it shows that we have a
major disaster in at the educational
system in Mexico inclusive the private
sector not only the public sector but
the university the private universities
and the school univer private schools
has not given the results we had
expected
i have not had the chance to participate
in the electric reform in i was already
Washington in 1997 it was energetic and
the energetic reform was privatization
perform it did not happen because the
terms and conditions that was implied
the reforms of 92 and 95 and the the gas
all that had no problems in the reforms
and know that get developed but this one
this one yet still have problems the
reform with payments of Mexican soils
had reformed that it did not have a
privatization issue it was just a way of
for making the company stronger and it
was way too short of what originally was
thought of because at the beginning we
accepted there was not a constitutional
reform because of what what reason was
maybe it was a political reason but
without a constitutional reform it's not
enough to bring our around the reform
their payments needs there which is to
be able to partner with whomever they
want whatever um for whatever amount of
money they want of with whomever they
want and not the they're like charge Oh
worked that they only bring more
rigidity that it's very impressed in
possible to operate one was a
privatization reform and the other one
was not was not one I was not pretend to
be one we're getting to the end of our
chat and I feel the last three people
with are going to be have very short
very short questions
and they'll be together so you can all
answer them together the last brief a
question which is a little general about
the Democratic tides do you believe that
the young democrats could democracy in
Mexico can reach citizens the article
talks about the architect in
productivity and all that but without a
modern democracy America like America
how can we see that the powers like the
Supreme Court it's a desire to influence
on the elections do you believe that
that the Mexican democracy can reach the
the parties can reach the citizens are
they willing to fight are they going to
continue of a political fight thanks for
the first question the second question
implementation of reforms because actor
mentioned the associate society to
motivate the politicians but I think
that it's going to get reach a certain
point and it has to also reach unions
and other monopolies power and who are
also members of the unions who could
also weaken it thank you for the second
question in let the last one my question
is on the reform to polit polit
political reform how can you reconcile
that even though the Mexican electorate
has the possible if it wants to elect
majority in the Congress or for a
president note it hasn't done it how do
you confide in the this message to the
electorate to reconcile it to the extent
to reinforce in the second round this
mechanism how do you interpret this
message even though it's been able to do
it hasn't done thank you to those who
have made questions and to those who
have asked before now
into the answers Jorge or x'ed or
whoever would you like to express about
the first and the first and the last I
think there are many things that Mexico
can do to reach the citizens to the
power or to reach the political system
that are more or less things that are
well known in other countries and that
there are no reason why they can't
function they might not function
perfectly or or be have all the
characteristic desirable caster
characteristics I'm just going to give
two examples in the chamber the lay the
law on collective action suits in Mexico
it was it was in the chamber and then
they removed it at class action lawsuits
in the Senate they they they were in the
Senate and now it's stalled in the
deputy chamber something so simple as
class action suits in Mexico we have not
been able to achieve there is in
Colombia Brazil Chile in all of Latin
America and let's not even talk about
the United States or Canada there is no
form the only thing that we have is the
fiscal fiscal fiscal of gin or the
general attorney on consumerism that
that doesn't sue anybody even if we had
one so it's a very typical example of
approaching the citizenship it's very
simple and the same thing is certain
about the independent famous candidates
they're not they don't solve everybody's
problems they're there they're not
magicians
when I hear about people in Mexico
intelligent and they say they're also a
pain juris and if they don't it doesn't
matter and that's why I'm so perplexed
because I don't know which of the two
they are and i also talked about the
chicken chili patent abhiya commented on
this the ambassador I understand that
this service service surveys exit
surveys of the voters omena mistahs were
divided 64 a 20 panera and 20 abstain
which what says that with a little bit
more of Frey boats out of this universe
the concert ation would have won in
light of the mark the Marco isn't
anything to convince his voters I don't
know if you know who he is or not to
vote for fray if he had made or a lot a
little bit it's nothing impossible that
the two or three points that they lost
they could have won my eye and I asked
myself they didn't have it the
independent candidates didn't have any
impact in Chile it can be a bad impact
or a bad impact according to the voters
of the concert ation but I don't think
that it's been the voter saw it badly of
Sebastian Pinera I think that it's a
topic I think we have two very concrete
elements what the last question would
refer to this electorate systems are
based on induce the type of political
system that they want not the rivers
it's been as cordova said in his an
essay and said before because we all
know that you can manipulate or age in
size
the electorate to achieve whatever
result that you want there's electorate
systems that systematically get
majorities and others that have never
resulted in majorities they appoint the
important thing is to decide as a
society as a country what is what is
what do we want and then and then
transfer that to the electorate system
to be more aware of that objective not
the reverse I don't know really I can't
say if Mexico really does want a
majority for example practically all the
states of the Republic our part duties
are one single party the country is
single party really and all this those
states are very single party and so all
states there's a majority both on a
legislation level and executive level it
may be may be but what's important is
that that's first to know what the
country wants it's very difficult to
know what's important to know is what
does this society want and to propose
those objective to us and then trance
and then make the electorate and the
citizen produce that I understand that
there can be other points of view but
for me I thank you very much actor well
he's Santiago said it very well in the
economic environment proposed in the
small si the change of emphasis is a
radical change not to talk about how to
fight against poverty which is an
obsession of Mexican politics and its
history but it's like it has taken a
path very contrary to the idea idea of
fighting poverty and to begin thinking
about how to create richness which are
very very different things
the same for the political reform we're
proposing a change of emphasis that is
turning out to be a big change the
reform designed to design system so that
there is majorities click clear majority
in the Congress we come from a design
and therefore the things are like this
it's not because mexicans want this but
there's a design in the architecture in
event 96 which came in at a time a
country hiding from the abusive means
never legitimate that it never
legitimized legitimized by other means
and there was agreement of the political
forces at that time that to design
something so nobody could have a
majority again in the congress under the
supposition that if nobody had the
majority in the Congress the political
actors would be obligated to agree well
the first question worked nobody has the
majority in congress it's been decreed
in the constitution where it says that
nobody can have an over-representation
of over eight points that once that says
that the force that could have the
majority in the Congress fifty plus one
would have to obtain forty-three percent
of the places in the election this in a
party system in mexico is impossible
what we've seen is everything all to the
contrary percent lower percentages every
day obtained in the elections federal
federal elections it worked that nobody
has the majority but from 96 the first
victim of this system was said do
from this the parties have not agreed
they have blocked them been able to
block they block each other the idea is
that the formula doesn't work it's not
the political culture it the what
doesn't work is the engineering we
accept that the political parties if
there's no majority they're going to
they're going to block each other at the
upon collaborating and that's what's
happened in the last 14 years and let's
establish a system where democratically
built the majorities in the Congress and
and these proposals are oriented towards
that and the second round with the elect
legislative elections with proposals and
candidates in the second round wise
should the the political election carry
the legislation and a president with the
faculties and capacities to have
initiative in the government or in the
induction of the agenda of the Congress
with capacity of veto and capacity to be
able to defend themselves and to be
responsible that brings the and capacity
of to initiate laws that are fundamental
that the Congress will not be able to
block to transform or to accept within
an amount of a period of time but this
is the initiative this is the sense of
this proposal to generate majority to
change the previous agreement and to
look for one that it does generate it
does not um any politician the serious
politician that has seen very closely
they legislative process and the process
of decision making from the reform of
1996 had to arrive to the conclusion
that
it's not the president or the party's
political parties that they are asking
for the country to move but it is that
agreement any precedent that arrives
probably will have the same situation
the president's Alicia and Fox can't and
Calderon to all this candidates as they
are in the way and at first they should
have the same idea of what doing the
reform right now because all this
candidates and especially those of the
indica when they will have to have very
clear that it will be for their
advantage to win if they have their home
in order if they want to win which this
means to refer reforge the presidency
the biggest obstacle that is absolutely
clear that has an initiative like this
one I know said that if the pine wins is
not going to win for much more than what
he won and that a precedence will be in
the same condition that he is he knows
the PRI that the candidate of the PRI
has to win the presidency is that his
triumph comes with a majority in the
Congress and the less that understand
this are the ones who seem to be more in
line to win this has not worked because
cerrito has been a bureaucrat a
technocrat fox was a fool and Calderon
is a Pnina and does not know how to
govern and we know how to govern and how
to obtain the majority's the Brazilian
way so we don't need the biggest reforms
in the law we know how to we know how to
do it yes we can
that is the biggest obstacle of this
reform that the pre the pre group have
this idea that they know how to govern
independent of the laws that have are in
place for the political reform so we are
going to see with that we are going to
close the session a very big applause
you